машини їздять
Всім доброго дня
добрий оскільки Україна це Атака країна
яка точно може захистити себе яка на
сьогоднішній день бореться за свою
територію за своє чисте небо мирне небо
І сьогодні тут і вчора були акти
[музика]
вісти для того аби до нас ще чіткий
меседж що Росія - це країна-агресор що
Іран - це країна-агресор що Білорусь на
сьогоднішній день граючи по правилам
Кремля та Путіна це країна-агресор тому
у громадськості є запитання у
громадськості є позиція і сьогодні ми її
озвучимо тут Тому Я запрошую до слова
пані Ірини Геращенко народний депутат
України
Дякую дорогі колеги Дорогі друзі
гості столиці Ми дякуємо всім хто не
байдужий і хто зібрався сьогодні під цим
приміщенням в центрі Києва прекрасного
Мирного Києва який дружно ставиться до
всіх країн незалежно від їх географії ми
депутати Верховної Ради України і
сьогоднішній ранок почали суспільний
кулінарний наш ранок бумбосховищі так
само як весь Київ Тому що чергове було
оголошено повітряну тривогу тому що твій
смертоносний груз іранський шахіди
принесли сьогодні до Києва до Київщини
до України і хочемо сказати що дійсно це
правда що на жаль сьогодні сформована
терористичний Альянс у складі Російської
Білорусь
очолює сьогодні саме проголошений цей
так званий президент який ожився в
любові братській до Україні але дав свою
територію для того щоб вбивати мирних
українців і на жаль Іран Іран який
сьогодні єдиний по суті
продає дрони ці
в народі вже назвали літаючими
балалайками але це не смішно тому що ці
шахіди несуть смерть українським містам
кого вбивають з цих друзів мирних
громадян вчора в Україні в Києві
загинула кілька мирних мешканців це
молода юна жінка яка чекала первістка її
чоловік Літні люди і це відбувається по
території всієї країни і власне ми як
депутати Верховної Ради України а тут
присутні Мої колеги і Олексій Гончаренко
який сьогоднішній ранок почав з того що
він зареєстрував проект заяви щодо Ірану
це наша коліжанка Я думаю найкраща
можлива експертка сфері міжнародних
взаємин у парламенті це Іванка
климпоштинсація ми вважаємо що парламент
Сьогодні має бути разом з українцями і
більш жорстко без жорстко вимагати від
світової спільноти реагувати на те що
відбувається з цим міжнародним
терористичним ділянку очевидно що Іран
має нести відповідальність за свої дії і
можливо сьогодні ми бачимо не покаране
зло тому що
взимку з 2020 року було збито
український цивільний літак і Вибачте
якщо весь світ сьогодні розслідує
голосно збиття mh17 то так само голосно
ми маємо вимагати розслідування
міжнародної експертизи і допуску до
чорних скриньок міжнародних експертів
збитого українського лайнера не
замовчувати це тому що вибачте тоді були
спроби навіть дискредитувати наших
ключики дискредитувати наших Екіпаж
немає сьогодні сумніви що це був теракт
до якого були причетні На жаль і
російські спецслужби і ми маємо почути
відповіді Хто збив український літак хто
до цього причетний друге якщо ми
сьогодні говоримо про санкцію до Ірану
від всього світу то Україна має це
почати ми знаходимося поряд
і сьогодні всі політичні сили
об'єдналися в одному В нас немає влади
опозиції ми єдині в одному в захисті
територіальної цілісності суверенітету
України Так ми можемо сьогодні апелювати
і дати тут пропозиції РНБО що перше ми
станції має вести Україна проти тихий
осіб юридичних і фізичних Ірану хто
причетний до створення
безпілотників до їх продажу Російській
Федерації до їх обслуговування бо
говорять що начебто запускається не з
окупованого Криму що там якісь
інструктори є іранські в окупованому
Криму Вибачте будь ласка так не діють
країни які хочуть жити в мирі з іншими
країнами і звичайно ми Закликаємо всі ці
організації міжнародні які демонструють
Сьогодні на жаль свою імпотенцію
прокинутись це і ООН і
ракбезно номера бути Росію що незаконно
займає е місце в радбезі ООН і просто
терористичний Альянс карате санкціями
але першими має бути Україна тому
позиція наша Я думаю що її має
підтримати весь парламент До речі ми
закликали сьогодні коли всі фракції
доєднатися до цієї акції відбуваються
під посольством Ірану
в місті Києві дуже важливо
що вагу вам на ці дії і прийняти
відповідну заяву тоді коли буде офіційне
засідання ви знаєте ми не оголошуємо
зараз весільні засідання в тому числі
через іранські дрони які кошмари Київ
Вибачте будь ласка це це посольство
сьогодні безпосередньо при до того що
ваше посольство може залишитись без
світла без тепла а отут можуть бути
вбиті люди які вбиваються іранськими
дронами ганьба
Дякую дуже Шановні колеги я хотів би
по-перше подякувати всім хто сьогодні
прийшов для того щоб ми висловили свій
протест е-е іранському режиму тому що це
ніяк знаєте я їх навіть не хочу називати
Влада чи ще якось цейранський режим це
режим терористичний Він має бути
визнаний таким терористичним режимом
Україна мають бути введені санкції проти
цього режиму мають бути розірвані тим
відносини з цим режимом які що робить
тут зараз прапор країни яка сьогодні
вбиває українців що роблять їхні
представники дипломатичні тут сидячи ви
нові цілі знаходять де треба
атакувати е-е словами а максимально
простягнути руку іранські опозиції яка
сьогодні бореться за демократію в цій
державі це нормальне майбутнє цієї
держави тому що вона там є але цей режим
який там сьогодні існує терористичний
режим він знищує все всередині держави
знищує українців про за межами Ірану він
є сьогодні частиною 202 от є вісім зла в
світі це Росія Північна Корея Іран оце
ті країни які сьогодні демонструють і
вони абсолютно антилюські що вони
антидемократичні що вони не знають що
таке слова права людини і сьогодні наше
завдання як України Тим більше що ми
сьогодні на передньому краю зайняти
максимально жорстку позицію перестати
загравати зранку розірвати нарешті
тільки відносини з Білорусі забрати
українського послав з Мінська всі ті
режими Лукашенка чи той режим а я тала
який сьогодні сформувався в Ірані всі
цілі антидемократичні режими Вони мають
бути зупинені знищені світла і жити
вільно а Україна має захистити своїх
громадян від цього який сьогодні від
цього іранського режиму Тому ми маємо
бути в перших рядах і ми маємо зайняти
дуже жорстку позицію щодо них і Україна
буде вільною Ми впевнені що в
майбутньому ієран буде вільний і мати
відносини можуть тільки з нормальною
демократичним керівництвом яке
коли-небудь вира не буде а сьогодні
маємо наближати цей момент незвичайно
перемога друзі Буде за нами ніякими
іранськими сусідами ніякими своїми
погрозами потім нічого не може зробити з
нашою армією він програє нашій армії і
тому він атакує наших жінок дітей
електростанції глибоко в тилу але це
водія - це Путіна і разом з ним мається
генетичні злочинні режими такі як іранці
дякую
друзі Україна сьогодні стоїть на
передньому краї захисту демократичних
цінностей людських базових цінностей
насамперед людського життя і можливостей
реалізовувати свої задатки такі режими
як російський такий режим як іранський
такий режими як білоруський стоять
з боку антисвіту Україна
демонструє світ Україна представляє світ
і ми стоїмо і протидіємо антисвіту і
дійсно Російська Федерація
Відчуваючи що
неспроможна досягти військового воєнного
результату на полі бою терпляче від
Контр наступу українських славетних
гідних українських збройних сил поразку
за поразкою
вона вдається до того щоби посіяти хаос
щоб посіяти паніку страх серед громадян
України але ми як громадяни України вже
перейшли певну межу страховки Я думаю що
це те чого недооцінює кремлівський режим
який вдався до того щоб шукати допомоги
Серед таких самих злочинців які він сам
і зокрема отримав допомогу як і злочинця
Лукашенко який надав територію своєї
країни для того щоб звідти постійно йшли
атаки на наших мирні українські міста на
наших громадян на нашу інфраструктуру на
наш спосіб життя і зараз вдався до того
щоби закуповувати зброю від ще одного
режиму який
не терпить демократія і не терпить права
терпить прав людини а саме іранського
режиму Ми маємо всі підстави вважати що
в 20-му році на початку 20-го року
не випадковою була трагедія з
українським літаком у небі надто Ми
маємо все підстави вважати що російський
режим був
іранським і Це була одна один з вони
зараз зміцнили продажами закупівлею
зброї проти українських міст тому ми
сьогодні Закликаємо владу українську
владу виконавчу максимально швидко
зреагувати на ці протиправні дії кількох
режимів ми дійсно вважаємо що
дипломатичні взаємини як в Білорусію так
і з іраном мають бути негайно розірвані
ми вважаємо що всі ті залишки
безвізового
спілкування які ми маємо і зі ранами з
білоруською так само мають негайно бути
скасовані ми вважаємо що
Україна
просять чи від світу весь час допомоги
наполягаючи у світі демократичному світі
про посилення тиску на Росію на іранне
Білорусь має показувати приклад як цей
тиск має чинитися і очевидно що ми перші
маємо запроваджувати санкції проти цих
режимів Ми дуже сподіваємося що Верховна
Рада України повністю буде підтримувати
такий підхід і власне кажучи Цей підхід
знайде відображення також всіх діях
виконавчої влади України але сьогодні ми
тут перед цим посольством режиму який
сьогодні вбиває своїх громадян ми з вами
як громадяни України які прийшли не одну
революцію за наші права
дійсно підтримуємо громадян в їхній
боротьбі за право бути за право жити за
право розвиватися право мати державу яка
буде поважати кожного громадянина І тому
ми сьогодні тут щоб висловити свій
жорсткий протест в цій державі з якою ми
не маємо про що сьогодні говорити цьому
режимом з яким ми не маємо сьогодні про
що говорити і віримо що перемовити
демократичного Ірану дасть нам
можливість мати стосунки з цією країною
якою ми разом будемо відстоювати
справедливість будемо відстоювати мир і
безпеку в усьому світі а поки що
Хотілося би щоби цей прапор на
найближчий час допоки Іран не змінить
своєї політики допоки не перестане
продавати і продавати патрони зброю для
Росії щоб вбивати наших мирних громадян
щоби прапор не зумів А взагалі
підніматися в Києві в Україні
і ми хочемо звернутися до української
діаспори до всіх небайдужих людей в
усьому світі Ми дякуємо вам за те що
кожного тижня проходять Великодні акції
протест та лотів світових столицях щодо
агресивної політики Кремля щодо
агресивної політики Путіна в Росії і
росіян тому що це повне відповідальність
кожного росіянина за війну в Україні
вони обирали цю владу вони її
підтримують і вони мають понити повну
відповідальність ми Закликаємо
найближчими днями провести так само
акції протесту в усіх світових столицях
де є посольства Ірану і висловити
протести відносно того що сьогодні ця
країна є співучасником тероризму
тогочасна кому вбив українців і
пропонуємо вшанувати пам'ять всіх
українців циві військових загиблих в цій
жорстокій несправедливій війні вбити
дронами шляхідами
хвилиною мовчання
[музика]
ми не побачимо Ми зробимо все для того
щоб була відповідальність за кожного
вбитого за кожного пораненого за кожен
об'єкт підвищеної інфраструктури і
відповідати за це буде країна терорист
Російська Федерація і всі співучасники в
тому числі незаконний президент Білорусь
як він себе називає Лукашенка і всі
причетні до продажі Росія зброї якої
вбивають українців
буде тобі урожай так як відьма скажене у
нас зараз прямий ефір на канал
європейської солідарності скажіть
по-перше по-перше вітаю
ви всі бачите
Розкажіть будь ласка які кроки ми можемо
зробити щоб позбавитись від цього
посольства взагалі що ми можемо зробити
з іраном і що вже наскільки я читав вашу
сторінку було зроблено сьогодні зранку
Я радий
[музика]
які ми спонсором тероризм та звернення
від випадіння до всього світу для того
щоб були
від як ми бачимо вже з'явилося заява
міністра і закордонних справ кулеби і
каже що коли Дніпро розвивати відносини
зігранам тобто почався правильно процес
наше завдання назвати все своїми іменами
тому тільки так і не закриватись собі
депутаторами ми маємо бути на стороні
добра завжди Слава Україні Героям слава
дякую вам так буде в тобі вже так як
відьма скаже писанку спишу Любу
з тобою
без дітей залишу батька твоя
смердю заспокою
ють
Доброго здоров'я
буде тобі
Привіт Привіт
Як тебе звати Чого ти сюди прийшов
сьогодні
на дві частини
цивілізований для тих хто підтримав
виступ України наразі Іран є країною
терористів вона постачає Росії зброя яка
ває і мирних киян і тому я тут щоб
сказати що Іран це країна дякую
[оплески]
так друзі це посольство Ірану
[музика]
що треба робити зараз українці
до того постачання зброї
в країні агресору Російської Федерації
яка Луганської зброї бобить мирне
[музика]
мистецтво
так званий холодомор який вони хочуть
нам влаштувати цією зимою це неправильно
якщо Вони думають що вони просто
продають комусь зброю то це так не вийде
бо немає для себе усвідомити і що вони
[музика]
на території України
щоб вони до влучними до того що
тут Зараз і сьогодні боїться Злочин і
вмирають абсолютно не в чому не повинні
мирні люди на ваші питання і
безумовно нас чекає дуже важка зима і
треба було прислуховуватись і виконувати
всі поради які будуть
[музика]
яблучкою владою так і сказали і так далі
і
[музика]
саме головне ви втрачати віри в те що ми
переможемо все рівно те що правда на
нашому боці і ми виставимо обов'язково і
відстоюємо нашу Україну і відкладуємо і
все буде добре А скажіть чи могли б дати
5 от якихось чітких порад типу Тривожний
чемоданчик зібрати і так далі бо ми
бачимо що сьогодні немає електроенергії
в Житомирі на Троєщині сьогодні зранку
ні в зв'язку нічого от щоб щоб ви
порадили
нічого недавно вчора Ми якраз вже
знайомились з такою ногою вона яка
отбокс э-э тобто такі тривожний
чемоданчик в якому є
необхідні засоби освітлення і окріву які
на батарейках вони автономні від
електромережі і таким чином на якісь
перший період можна себе забезпечити
світлом і мінімальним теплом якщо такі
кликаутбуці можливо зібрати плоскоруч
закупивши
е-е найближчому магазинчику і
фонарики і
обігрівачі батарейки і зарядні пристрою
для цього і е-е
слава Україні геро
Ям Слава Україні
усе україна!
[оплески]
та дівчата кричать Іран - це спонсор
тероризму
[музика]
багато
росіянських Ботів не бігло тоді ще з
усього їм не вистачає
[музика]
Скажімо так тих 200-х яких вони
отримують кожного дня вирішили ще
[музика]
ще в коментарях побіситися тому друзі
підтримуйте трансляцію лайком
[музика]
її у Фейсбуці
в Інстаграмі чому ні
[музика]
Вітаю Скажіть будь ласка Чого ви
сьогодні сюди прийшли
що вони вбивці українців щоб Вони
зупинилися Ми хочемо жити
а вони хочуть нас брати
дякую вам дуже
[музика]
Привіт
Розкажи як тебе звати І чому ти сьогодні
сюди сьогодні прийшла з таким
класним плакатом
України
дякую дякую
а
мене Ну хто надув усіх Привіт скажеш
пару слів
Ми зараз на прямій трансляції
європейської солідарності Що ти хочеш
сказати людям чому взагалі ви сьогодні
сюди прийшли Я дивлюся ви зробили дуже
багато таких класних плакатів
[музика]
відбувається
той хто говорить простір над нами
безпеки
України
друзі Вітаю з нами тепер на зв'язку
Дінара наш депутат Київської ради
дінар Розкажи будь ласка
оці іранські дрони які прилітали і все
що прилітають на нашу землю ми їх зараз
не відбиваємо і Таке враження ніби
здалося 24 лютого
багатьом зараз страшно Розкажи що робити
українцям як і їм не випускати руки
[музика]
числа стався дуже масштабна Цера завдяки
якому
шоколадно-тетами
знаєте люди спокійно зрозуміли що ага
Бабах це і пішли це зібрали чемоданчик
податкова хтось там дуже багато там
тільки додав Я особисто цей момент
хокейті я зрозуміла Окей треба писати
зверху оскільки відпочинок наприклад
тобто Якщо порівняти з 24-м тобто жовтий
і не зрозуміло сталося з нами а зараз
тільки знаєте
підвищується люди кажуть от
і ти розумі
єш зараз незважаючи на те що є ри
зики доця аби сказати своїй свій протест
та Ірану зупинилися свої просто
терористичні дії і ран має стати на бік
спеціалізаційного свіжу 30 Тріада Іран
Білорусі Росія - це свято
слово Різдвяна кінця світу Ми українці
стали поїздом
[музика]
Чортків і хоче може здаватися що це
незначна акція але кожна дія і кожен
крок до перемоги
тобі сказати І я теж не розумію що
конкре
ніхто не пояснив чому
вигарасах Героям слава дякую
давайте трошки плакатів подивимось
друзі не забувайте ставити лайки на
трансляцію це дуже важливо особливо
зараз ваші лайки це фактично кулі в
нашій інформаційній війні а особливо
зважаючи на те що європейська
Солідарність не пускають на
телемарафон що Зелена Влада включила
блок
не буде і кохаю місто накриє крило
та заступиться місто поділиться теплом
поширюйте
ся
у нас буде відбуватися перетворення який
напевно кожного хто буде проходити тут
по-перше нагадаю А по-друге ми зможемо
показати рамського посольство свою річну
цю позицію і ви йому конкретними діями
спонукати їх зупинити ці злочини на
території України і проти всього
цивілізаційного світу тому залишаємось і
зараз Ми продовжуємо
друзі зараз
наші активісти готуються до перформансів
хтось дає інтерв'ю журналістів
досить багато для акції особливо
зважаючи на те що
мітинги зараз в у військовий час
Скажімо так не дозволені проте усі все
розуміють як поліція так і люди і
сьогоднішній мітинг під вбивцями під
посольством вбивць які продають свої
мопеди
Росії і які потім
вбивають українських дітей тільки вчора
загинула ціла сім'я
українців тому що цей Дрон влучив у
житловий будинок
ми переконані що якщо вся Україна
сьогодні на цей момент буде працювати
інформаційно перш за все друзі
інформаційно тобто як я вже казав Лайкер
проти Ірану
то рано чи пізно цей меседж завдяки у
тому числі вам не тільки
депутатам не тільки
уряду завдяки в першу чергу Вам цей
меседж що Іран - це спонсор тероризму
він дійде до
урядовців урядовців західних країн і
вони почнуть
діяти вони почнуть впроваджувати санкції
[оплески]
пане Олександр бачив пише чим дальше
Україна ні капітолирует тем больше
инвалидов и детей сирот в России але
питання у тому що проблема в тому що
Росія сама обрала
іти на нас війною і вона отримала те що
не хотіла але те що дуже хотіли українці
починаючи з 14-го року починаючи з 24
лютого
і зараз Ми продовжуємо битися хто на
фронті
Дякуємо нашому захисникам Дякуємо за те
що нас
є благодійники Дякуємо за те що у нас є
Волонтери які збирають ці кошти які
привозять їх на фронт
[музика]
Привіт Ми зараз ведемо пряму трансляцію
на канал європейської солідарності
Розкажи чому ти сьогодні тут з таким
класним плакатом
і таким чином Іран і Білорусь
постачаючи зброю допомагаючи Росію це
все робити стають посольниками
терористів просто
без ніяких там таких
складних алгоритмів Це просто терористи
вони
сьогодні просто маємо доносити все це
світло для того щоб показати що ці три
країни
ви нічого передбачити режимами які
сьогодні
дуже розважали
Отримали свою критичну
частину нарешті припинили
терористичної Європи Дякую тобі дуже
[музика]
друзі роздали чорні Літачки
або пісню
[музика]
[сміх]
Друзі на сьогоднішній день зібравшись
Тут ми показуємо свій протест незважаючи
на тривоги незважаючи на агресію
незважаючи на продовження агресивних
атак з боку іранських Дронів
ми Закликаємо усі міжнародні засоби
інформації поширювати те наскільки
українці на сьогоднішній день боряться
за свою незалежність наскільки українці
готові відстоювати свою територіальні
цінність Ми сьогодні тут солідарна
молодь разом з перформансом хочемо
повісити ці чорні
Літачки Так звані мопеди так звані
ранські дрони які
простягнені кров'ю кров'ю дітей
вагітним щенок
кров'ю у всіх невинних мирних цивільних
людей які просто проходили крізь
перехрестя або йшли на роботу і були під
атакою іранських Дронів російських
ракети білоруського режиму
на сьогоднішній день
наше життя
загрозою
ми Закликаємо усіх надати нам зброю ми
Закликаємо міжнародні
організації посилити санкції ми
Закликаємо іранські уряд зробити
максимальні санкції виробника і тим хто
намагається продати більше і більше
Дронів
країнам терористам
саме українці зупинять цю візу зла
Росія Білорусь Іран зла Росія
Росія Білорусь
[музика]
гетьманство
[сміх]
[оплески]
[музика]
друзі Я Нагадую що прямо зараз ми
знаходимося під
і показати посольство
в Києві міжнародного інституціями
що ми не будемо
дозволяти
будь-які країні посягати на наше життя
наших дітей і наших жінок тому прошу вас
стати сюди в коло І повісити це
смертельний
що
просто кожен день
розбиває наше життя
Розкажи будь ласка що це символізує
кожен раз коли ми чуємо або бачимо
іранські дрони одразу це
асоціюється з символом смерті
і оскільки останні події
сприяли тому що дуже багато людей бито
цивільних і вчорашня подія людини якої
знала Вікторія яка працювала у
звичайному магазині була вагітна і разом
з чоловіком загинула тому ми хотіли би
цими чорними літаками дронами які
окривавлення по суті тут фарба але це
наша з вами
кров це наша жертва
В нашій боротьбі за нашу незалежність і
в цій війні
Ми хочемо показати що кожен іранський
Дрон покривавлений українською крові
дякую
поліція знімає ногу про
Напевно вона не знає що ми теж будемо
Стрім
А що поліція знала що ми теж ведемо
стрім з посольства
Ірану потрібно зробити вподобайку і з
репостити і буду знати не тільки поліція
будуть знати
урядовці інших країн
бо Чим більше ми уваги привернемо
цією акцією
тим більше потім
санкції
санкції та всього іншого
обмежень і
визнання держави терориста тим більше
шансів у нас на це
і зараз це дуже важливо Це важливо не
тільки
Для нас це важливо не тільки для
українців
це важливо для всього цивілізованого
світу тому що ці дрони можуть продавати
інших країнах Росія може кидати ці дрони
куди завгодно будь-яку країну
поки поки захід нам допомагає Ми
тримаємо оборону
і тільки завдяки нам зараз
захід спить спокійно друзі
[музика]
будь ласка тому
європейська Солідарність Особисто я та
всі люди які сьогодні прийшли
Дякую вам за увагу
Сподіваємось що ви максимально поширите
цей стрім Сподіваємось що ви максимально
про лайкаєте його
і
[музика]
підтримки російського режиму
терористичного і я вже думав завершувати
стрім але зараз Дінара розповідає Що
є іграшка
яка була тої дитини яка вчора загинула
Вона ще не народилася
але от ви можете побачити
Так виглядає Іран
тому дякуємо вам за увагу
підтримуйте українське дивіться
українське
і не забувайте в соцмережах
робити все для того щоб
Іран в очах усіх іноземців став державою
терористом бо так і є бо сьогодні
іранські дрони вбивають українців
бувають українські дітей